in the beginning there was the big
bangang a small region of space that
later would become the entire visible
Universe began with light let there be
light but what came before the Big Bang
that primordial light according to many
cosmologist it was inflation the spark
that ignited the hot big bang that we
are made of whose materials produced the
hydrogen helium and other elements that
would become Stars which would later
explode and become the heavy ele that
we're made of but what caused inflation
and how did our universe begin seemingly
from nothing a single origin point to
the teaming Cosmos filled with light
matter and even cosmologists that can
contemplate how it all began while
inflation provides a very compelling
description of the origin of the
universe and how the big bang unfolded
you might be surprised to hear not
everybody is in favor of it a recent
paper suggests that something else could
have been the starting point of our
universe two astrophysicists including
AI Lo from Harvard and his colleague
Sunny vosi from the University of trento
wrote a letter to the astrophysical
journal and in it they detailed a brief
history of the Big Bang inflationary
Theory and where it may have G wrong and
most importantly how it can be tested
and not proven but falsified for that is
the job of an experimental physicist
like me all of science is built on the
scientific method the core principle of
testing hypotheses with data anyone can
propose some Grand theory about how the
universe or how microscopic particles
work but whether or not anyone believes
it is based on two things whether or not
it explains phenomena that are or have
been observed and whether or not it
could predict future phenomena in other
words good science should be able to
explain or predict and sometimes it can
do both and there are many examples of
this through the history of physics and
cosmology however there's a disadvantage
in cos cosmology because the time scale
for evolutionary processes in the
universe are unimaginably large we
really can't make future predictions
because they'll be virtually untestable
so everything in cosmology operates on
the scale of billions of years we must
therefore look for things that have
variability now it's interesting to note
that there are so few things that vary
in the heavens that we have names for
those things they are called planets
which come from the Greek word to wander
and even that's what a plane does a
plane is just a planet without a tea it
moves stars on the other hand are
basically fixed in space as far as
cosmologist lifetimes are concerned
stars on the verge of melting down and
collapsing have probably been that way
long since any cosmologist even could
consider their properties so we must
focus on events where there's a wealth
of data that we have and many many
events that we can see and explain while
there only is one Cosmos there are many
objects within the cosmos Supernova
stars planets and even entire galaxies
and clusters of galaxies so we make
measurements of the present day and make
models of the universe's history of how
it looked in the past and try to explain
how they came to be but there's a
problem in the way that we do this it's
called the lack of falsifiability
according to Carl popper one of the most
popular of all philosophers of Science
in order for something to be considered
scientific it must be falsifiable not
provable let's take a simple example
hypothesis like all apples are red this
premise could be proven wrong if we
spotted a single green apple all
testable and effectively proven
hypotheses are marked by this kind of
falsifiability it's not the only
criteria after all astrology makes many
many predictions many of those are not
only falsifiable but they're falsified I
was predicted to be 6'8 blonde and
blue-eyed that didn't turn out to be
true according to my mother at least so
there's always something that if you see
it completely disproves the hypothesis
and proving that it can't exist is how
you can qualify or test the hypothesis
there's an old saying the exception that
proves the rule it doesn't mean that it
proved the rule it means that it tests
proving in the form of testing the
problem with the big bang inflationary
scenario according to Dr vazi and Dr
lobe is that it isn't falsifiable you
can perhaps have evidence circumstantial
evidence for Cosmic inflation as many
many pieces of data have had and as
we've discussed with Michael Turner and
other eminent cosmologists ranging from
Neil turo to will Kenny we have plenty
of phenomena that seem to fit and be
explained by inflation but they're not
definitive proof in other words there
are other theories that also predict
these that are not consistent with
inflation so let's dig into this deeper
where did the Big Bang come from well we
don't know but as an idea it began in
the early 1900s around 1910 astronomer
vesto slier and Carl vers separately
measured the spectrum of distant
galaxies this tool spectroscopy has been
discussed many times in this Channel and
will continue to be it's so powerful it
allows you to measure the recessional
velocity of objects in our galaxy or in
distant galaxies away from the Milky Way
a few years after slier and vert's
discoveries that almost all galaxies or
extra Galactic nebula or nebula or
spiral nebula as they were called back
then it seemed as if all of them were
moving away or having a red shift a
recessional velocity that was strange
cuz other nebula like the Orion Nebula
had components that were moving towards
and Away the Earth in the same decade in
1915 Einstein's work on general
relativity seemed to suggest that the
Universe can't be static it either could
be expanding or converging but there was
no way that it could be stationary
unless as Einstein did he inserted the
so-called cosmological term of vacuum
energy density that balanced the
collapsing nature of the ordinary matter
in the universe and counteracted it he
later called that his biggest blunder
and I like to think about what his
career could have been like if he didn't
make that blunder imagine it so later on
Edwin Hubble came up with observations
that established Hubble's Law based on
Celia lit's predictions of the
relationship discoveries of the
relationship between the period and the
Luminosity of so-called seate variables
now we know that as lit's law so Hubble
with the combination of distance
measurements from levit and red shift
measurements from slier at all had a
prediction that every Galaxy was
actually red Shifting the farther away
it was the faster it was receding what
Hubble showed was that the Universe was
not static it was not even collapsing it
was expanding so what Einstein had
suggested to obtain a static Universe
was shown to be impossible the universe
was changing it was Dynamic it
definitely wasn't static putting them
both together it was clear that the
Universe had been expanding for a long
time going backwards in time if you
think about it as a movie reeled
backwards in time you'll steadily get to
a denser and denser universe everything
got closer together as you went back in
time and this agreed with the ideas of
lametra who's a Belgian Catholic priest
who had come up with the model before
Hubble's connection between red shift
and distance latra did that back in 1927
he described the origin of the universe
is a so-called Primeval Atom a nucleus
that exploded somehow into an expanding
configuration where all the matter in
the universe was confined to a giant
atom effectively he predicted that
eventually this expansion would result
in the expansion of the matter particles
that had come together as galaxies and
they would all be moving away except for
a handful that are gravitationally bound
to the Milky Way or we're bound to it in
the case of the Andromeda galaxy or the
satellite galaxies the magalin clouds
that orbit around the Milky Way those
are the only exceptions only a handful
10 or 20 galaxies are coming towards us
or static with respect to the Milky Way
and 100 billion other galaxies are
moving away from us the second pillar of
the big Bang's narrative is the cosmic
microwave background the leftover heat
after the fusion of the first elements
in the periodic table is the light
source that we call the cosmic micro
back ground or CMB these The Relic
photons the leftover heat these are
particles the earliest particles of
light the earliest oldest photons they
traced themselves to the hot dense phase
in the first few minutes of the big bang
and as the universe cooled off from the
first few minutes out to 380,000 years
when the first atoms formed so the
duration from the first nuclei to form
in the first 3 minutes of the universe's
history to the CNB production when the
first atoms formed was 380,000 years
inflation explains that energy necessary
to create the first nuclei which would
later become the first atoms and it does
so by suffusing the universe with heat
and light which is the result of the
Dynamics of a so-called scalar field
evolving under what's called Slow Roll
from a higher energy state to a lower
energy State a true vacuum State and
that releases energy as it does in Phase
Transitions and those heating packs that
you use when you're skiing or in a phase
transition of sodium acetate like I did
in a demonstration at the Royal
Institution recently there are many many
people who suggested along the history
of inflation that inflation is not
correct the three most fierce critics of
the inflationary Paradigm have been
guests on this podcast Paul steinhardt
Neil turro and Sir Roger Penrose winner
of the 2020 Nobel Prize but inflation
makes other predictions as well
including the absence of observation of
magnetic monopoles which is also true
but there are many things that can
prevent magnetic monopoles from being
observed including they might not exist
p on the into the impossible podcast
Lord Martin Reese a British cosmologist
summarized it thusly Skeptics about
exotic physics may not be hugely
impressed by a theoretical argument to
explain the absence of particles that
are themselves hypothetical preventative
measurement can readily seem 100%
effective against a disease that doesn't
exist so getting back to vosi and L's
astrophysical Journal letter they intend
to solve the problem of the specific
testability or falsifiability of of
specific models of inflation they
suggest that any general model of
inflation will probably be falsifiable
but the whole inflationary Paradigm in
their words is not falsifiable so to
make it easier to study and characterize
different models of inflation and the
entire program of inflationary
falsification they proposed a model
independent criteria that would
discriminate between inflation and other
ideas of the early universe's formation
so what's the big idea well inflation
explains the absence of magnetic
monopoles by positing the hyper
superluminal expansion of SpaceTime such
that even if there were a huge density
of them in the early moments of the
universe's history by the time inflation
is over there might only be one in our
entire observable universe so they get
spread out too far to detect them well
vazzi and lob proposed that something
similar would happen not necessarily
with Magnetic monopoles but another
harbinger of inflation gravitons
primordial gravitational waves now
gravitons have never been detected
they're the particle analog of
gravitational waves in the same way that
photons are the quantum mechanical
particle instantiation of
electromagnetic waves according to L and
magazi the two researchers proposed that
in the early Universe primordial
gravitons would be diffused away forming
a cosmic gravitational background if
inflation as an abstract concept were
accurate this Cosmic gravitational wave
background or cgb would have been spread
out to being
undetectable therefore they argue if you
were to measure a cosmic graviton
background it would prove the whole
inflationary Paradigm wrong because
these should not be possible to observe
in the same way that inflation predicts
we should not be able to observe
magnetic monopoles observing
gravitational waves in their Quantum
form would prove the inflationary
Paradigm wrong or therefore it would
falsify it now the cgb sounds familiar
it's in resonance with the CMB the
cosmic microwave background whereas the
cosmic microwave background are
electromagnetic waves they're no longer
photons really although of course at a
Quantum level they are the cosmic
gravitational wave background or
graviton background is left over ripples
in SpaceTime at the quantum level
stretched out to Cosmic scales via the
expansion of the universe now we're
searching for that with many experiments
and we claimed a detection of that in
2014 as we talked about and many many
times and it is the subject of my book
losing the Nobel Prize available
wherever books are sold and click on the
link below to get whisked away we did
claim we detected B mode polarization
which would be indicative of the cgb the
cosmic gravitational way background
however in 2015 we essentially retracted
our conclusion saying that the signal
was primarily caused by dust we did so
in collaboration with the plank
experiment which had the data on dust
that bicep 2 lacked even looking at the
CMB like we've been doing our technology
hasn't reached the point of confirming
things one way or another another so
we're a little ways out for being able
to detect the cosmic gravitational wave
background and prove this once and for
all proving a paradigm wrong is helpful
in letting you observe what is possible
to detect so if agnosia and lobe are
looking for a way to make it falsifiable
they must also be proposing an
alternative that's the bouncing
cosmological model bouncing cosmological
models are not new they've been around
for a long time we've talked about it
with Anna Eis and others on this very
podcast so before the Big Bang they
posit that a universe came together and
bounce back and that bounce produced the
heat and energy but it did not require
fundamental quantum mechanical period it
could have been a classical bounce
leaving behind no Cosmic gravitons and
so that would allow falsifiability of
the inflationary model if that model
were correct there also other
cosmologies like string gas cosmology
we've talked about with my old Professor
Robert brandenberger here and so the key
message is that the CMB and its
polarization the very thing that I've
dedicated my experimental career to is
not used to prove models of cosmology we
cannot prove inflation or prove the
bouncing cosmology right or wrong all we
can do is falsify other Alternatives so
by observing the cosmic microwave
backgrounds B mode polarization if it
has the right properties and one hand
could falsify or reject models more
easily than it can actually prove models
and if you want to know more about these
alternative models click here for a
playlist that I've cultivated just for
you and don't forget to hit the like
button if you want to see more content
like this